for our next presenting duo we have
Peter Samuelsson who's a producer and
the founder of five charities for
children who are seriously ill homeless
or in foster care his 26 films include
Arlington Road wild Tom and viv and
Revenge of the Nerds Peter has been a
member of the nickel committee for two
decades and Eva Marie Saint is an Oscar
winner for on the waterfront
and unforgettable in North by Northwest
Eva Marie Saint is also an Emmy winner
and for the kids among us was a voice of
Katara in the animated series The Legend
of Korra she has served on the Academy
nickel fellowships committee for 30
years presenting the award to Caren
McDermott our Peter Samuelsson and Eva
Marie Saint
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's a nice high okay
I thought it was a shadow it's it's I
love the idea with the actors enact a
scene from a from one of these stories
it just brings it to life and you're all
wonderful I just have to say that actor
to actor Karen Nick Dom McDermott who
wrote lullabies of la haula she said
quote I felt compelled to tell this
story because I'm outraged that children
are being caged in America
as a former attorney specializing in
child abuse and neglect I know what the
trauma experienced by neglected children
looks like she wrote lullabies of La
Jolla this is a story of a fifteen year
old and her name is Dahlia she her
mother and brother made the Duras
journeys to the border her brother was
killed she is put in a cage and
separated from her mother she is a brave
young girl and makes friends with the
other children in the cage
she loves books and she reads them she
becomes their mother but she misses her
own mother one day a well-to-do white
couple visits the cage and mates Dahlia
they signed the papers
and drive her to her beautiful home by
the sea she goes to school and she tries
very hard to accept the situation
however she does miss her mother and she
is determined to find her eventually she
does and her mom working in a florists
shop
Karen McDermott who wrote lullabies of
lauhala said I felt compelled to tell
this story because I'm outraged that
children are being caged in America as a
former attorney specializing in child
abuse and neglect I know that the trauma
experienced by detective and abducted
children looks like and I would like to
invite her to come up right now
Oh No you're coming the man's coming up
it's no secret to anyone here that we
are living in dark and dangerous times
what perhaps we should be focusing on is
the role that audio visual storytelling
is playing in the gathering darkness
those who through demagoguery seek to
divide us to emphasize the sense of
other to make us hate each other they
understand through training in reality
television that schadenfreude is a
potent base human instinct meaning
enjoying the suffering of others
reveling indifference enjoying someone's
misfortune and their downfall
luckily audio visual storytelling can be
used equally well and perhaps much
better we hope for the forces of the
angels to prevail because the bully
pulpit that we are facing every time you
turn on news television has an antidote
and I'd like to suggest that all of us
here the professionals here whether your
creativity your art your science is
through acting or writing
or directing or producing or the myriad
other ways that we help to get films
made we should all be asking ourselves
in this time of peril and gathering
darkness what we can personally do
beyond the next 7th sequel to some
franchise which is based in using visual
special effects to defy the laws of
physics we should be asking ourselves
what can I do to make my world a little
less grim how can i generate empathy
through the power of my pen my voice my
camera how can I lift people up and
emphasize the commonality of mankind
which links us all what Karen McDermott
has done elegantly powerfully with
emotion with with technique with with
huge impact in lullabies of la haula is
to show us that this family that is
thrown into chaos from the moment that
they have to escape from evil that has
killed the son in the family through the
new evil that awaits them on the other
side of the tunnel into the United
States which separates mother from
daughter and in cages the 15 year old
what we understand is that family is
family that these people who speak a
different language who look a little bit
different perhaps they are us and we are
them and Karen by telling this
extraordinary story of personal bravery
of a 15 year old who actually realizes
that there is something the matter with
being fostered by a well-meaning but
tone-deaf white couple in their very
elegant
an expensive home and had being thrown a
lavish Kenzi an era where the only
Hispanic people present are herself and
the mariachi band there is something
wrong with that picture
and her being possessed to find her
mother which she finally manages to do
lifts us all up and shows us that even
in the face of evil done by people in
uniforms carrying guns and locking
children in cages
using our tax dollars even given that
even though you know Santa Jana said
those who forget the mistakes of history
are doomed to repeat them my thoughts go
to 1932 1933 1934 somewhere else and the
power of media in that time Leni
Riefenstahl and so forth
we need to every person here in the
Samuel Goldwyn theater needs to be
asking themselves as well as making a
living as well as getting my material
made as well as getting that next acting
assignment how can I actually use
whatever god-given skills I have to lift
up my world to emphasize what we all
have in common and to build bridges
rather than walls I have the great honor
with Eva Marie Saint to ask Karen
McDonald to come up and receive her
nickel fellowship in screenwriting
I didn't realize the power of that last
line until I heard you recite it thank
you so much
Tyrese Gibson I never thought of when
Alberto as sexy apparently he is he just
made more work for me Tyrese I have to
go in and add some scenes where he's
shirtless now
[Laughter]
thank you so much Peter Samuelsson and
Eva Marie saying this is such a dream
come true
thank you for putting so much thought
and generosity into that introduction I
have to say this whole Eva Marie Saint
thing is throwing me it would throw you
to thank you to the nickel committee
Joan white all of the nickel judges but
more than anyone tonight I need to thank
my students the people who inspired this
script first year composition students
at California State University Los
Angeles Cal State LA in the house
that surprises me because a couple of my
students asked me if they would get
extra credit for coming tonight I said
no but you'll get public recognition in
the academy award theater and they were
like but no extra credit in the fall of
2018 I knew I wanted to write about the
caging of migrant children in America I
was infuriated and I wanted to put a
face to the policy a family separation I
wanted us to see it through the eyes of
a child but I knew it was a difficult
subject to think about let alone write
about so I talked to my mexican-american
students about it and they said we'll
help you and they did my students helped
me with the Spanish they fact-checked me
they did they told me stories about
their families border crossings and
about the conditions in their home
countries and all of this informed the
scripts two of my students allowed me to
use their names
Thank You Juan Alberto for the use of
your beautiful name I'm sorry I had to
kill you
Thank You Stephanie for the use of your
beautiful name I'm sorry I had to kill
you too hey I had to kill some children
I was trying to make a point and I was
trying to make Eva Marie Saint cry I
don't I wasn't I wasn't trying but if
she was going to cry the cry I had in
mind was the one from the auction scene
and North by Northwest it was a
beautiful cry she just welled up so
beautifully thank you Michael for never
letting me give up no matter how hard I
try to Michael's favorite thing to say
to me is you got the goods I don't even
know where the goods are but thank you
to all my friends and family who support
my writing in an earlier version of the
script I named them all and then listed
all the reasons why I was thanking them
you would have hated it it was 12
minutes long I have one last thank you
to the meryl streep funded writers lab
for female screenwriters over 40
thank you for mentoring and empowering
mature women writers I attended the lab
two years ago
and I think we have some alumni here
tonight in the audience I want to end by
saying that I agree with Peter Samuelson
these are dark dark times but the wind
is coming I think thank you good night